when lelu lands in the back of Corbin's
taxi she doesn't know where she is and
she definitely doesn't know how to speak
English boom boom yeah I understand boom
though she picks up more and more
English as the movie progresses most of
the time lelu speaks a language Beyond
anyone's comprehension in reality the
words that lelu speaks were created by
director Luke basson just for this movie
bassan spent 15 years developing the
world of The Fifth Element and in all
that time he also spent some effort
creating a dictionary for the Divine
language bassan invented around 400
words so that lelu could in theory say
everything she needs to say through the
entire movie in a real language bassan
and Mila yovich both became so fluent in
the Divine language that they even used
it to communicate with each other while
filming